hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode welcome welcome hey
what's up beautiful people welcome to
another episode of get close I am Geo
and I'm bar and today I want to talk
about your loyalty to your children and
US specifically your loyalty to taika
okay so I've been thinking about this
for quite a bit
um and now I don't think I've ever
shared this with you I want to hear your
perspective on it so [__] who's a [__]
you you don't share we're supposed to be
vulnerable intimate and never hide
anything I can't believe in hiding this
whole time
um no I save it for the podcast of
course oh okay okay so
um
there's like two perspect or two stories
I heard
okay okay let me just say this sorry so
the first story
um is I had a girlfriend a few years
back and
um she was she had a boyfriend for many
many years and when you see them on
paper or you just see them in person you
think they're perfect you think they're
perfect for each other yeah then out of
the blue even for her she finds out he's
cheating on her right okay yeah
and through her
she didn't like do much digging because
it was pretty blatant once she saw one
piece of evidence that was it yeah
um but then you know when you find
something that's inconsistent with
either Behavior or a story they told you
or something now you start thinking back
to all these other instances that kind
of made you feel funny or weird and
you're like oh my God it all makes sense
now like this you know this these lies
or the cheating or whatever has been
going on for so long now that like when
I think to that one time when this
happened now I understand why it was so
weird because like red flags are obvious
but then there might have been orange
Flags so the orange flags are like oh
were those precursor signs yeah I mean
there weren't any Flags they were just
it was just something out of the norm
yellow flax sure okay we'll do yellow so
they're yellow flats and you're like oh
yes so then uh one time she remembers
um her boyfriend being out of town or or
uh one day she would she couldn't get a
hold of him I he said he was gonna hang
out with friends or something like that
maybe he did go out of town he's gonna
hang out with friends and she genuinely
thought something had happened to him
she's like it's not liking to not you
know respond to me even it like she's
not a clingy person but she was just
like oh this is weird like I hope he's
okay like never once is she thinking
like he's out there like the memes right
like what is he doing cheating on me
like that just wasn't their relationship
she's like holy crap this is not normal
behavior so she calls the mom she's like
hey do you know where so-and-so is like
I'm just trying to make sure he's okay
he says he's gonna be out but like he's
not even responding to my texts or
anything I just want to make sure he's
probably just in Glendora
um probably there's nothing to do in
Glendora it's probably not so the mom's
like Oh you know what he's here but like
he's in the shower or whatever like I'll
just have him call you back later the
mom created an alibi yes yes whoa yeah
yeah yeah so then well that's crazy this
particular story
um led me to be like okay well what type
of parent would I be
like would I be the one to get in the
middle and be like you know what no like
he's not like he's not here we should
see what's going on you know or like if
I knew something was up am I like
talking to taika and being like hey man
like this behavior is not good you
better fix it or do I like meddle it so
you're putting yourself in the cheater's
mom's shoes yeah or just not even the
cheater right let's say like it now
comes to do with the second story that I
was listening to is I think you had this
guy forgot his name he was uh he went to
prison or whatever oh Johnny Chang yeah
you had Johnny Chang on JK news and not
necessarily his specific story but
the idea of of my child who's now like
an adolescent or whatever committing a
crime that I am aware of and like would
I cover up for him like would I prevent
him
like would I help him not go to jail
like would I would I choose the law
versus my son's loyalty or like the
future like it's just this weird spot
do you know your answer
but they're they both I have two answers
oh you do I do all right well first of
all shout out to Johnny Chang AKA L
throw your dubs out there you know what
I'm saying it's dubbed all over the
world so what are dubs what is it what
is that um it's just the uh
little camaraderie group
um anyways it's back to the the topic at
hand here you're the only one that
deviated from it don't go anyways and
then try to bring it back when you're
the ass [__] derailed it in the first
place I can sense how much you love me
and I really appreciate it you're
welcome
I'm never changing for me that's [__]
e Z what's [__] the capital E and a
capital Z that was a double e but go
ahead
so for me it's a combination of a couple
of things
uh the first one is what is the actual
and absolute consequence of said action
that's one
number two is uh
did he mean it
and number three is where is it on my
scale of morals
and depending on what those ratings are
on those three scales determines if I
take my son home and I shoot him myself
in the head
excuse me or we flee the country and we
never look back okay let's just maybe
bring it back to the cheating then
because that other one's [__] extreme
well like if my son
turns out to be a psychopath right oh
yeah and then unfortunately he becomes a
person of mass violence right he's out
doing crazy [__] you would kill your own
son you would kill Tycho with your own
hands I would you wouldn't I know
because I'm a psychopath too so for me I
was about to [__] say do I need to
like no because for me everybody listens
to his podcast right now if I disappear
the way that I see it is parents are
responsible for their children right
yeah but we're not [__] Killers he
killed he bombs an entire airport yeah
I'm not a bomber 70 000 people yes he's
an [__] yeah but I might I can't take
my own kids hands what what do you do I
can't take his own my his life with my
own hands all right this is what I'll do
then at the court case I'm gonna be in
the jury and I'm just gonna go he's
guilty he's guilty he's guilty he's
guilty put him away put him away that's
what I'll do really yeah you'll you'll
[__] backstab your son like that I
have to why he is a detriment to this
world
he can't control himself he thinks he's
doing some he thinks he's eating
Pop-Tarts I'm just kidding but he's just
straight like obliterating people other
people's Sons no for real that you would
kill him I would
yeah yeah no questions asked that's
that's that is I'm like
I have to be responsible for what I
brought into this world and because of
what I brought into this world took away
what other people brought into this
world at that mass scale and we can tell
that there's just some wires loose or
something about his environment that was
not good
I got to be like you know what I'm so
sorry guys you would you try to
rehabilitate them or no what are you
doing obviously I'm gonna do my due
diligence you can't say Obviously you
just called yourself a cycle that's why
I said something crazy like 7 000 people
like missed that's what I'm talking
about we tried you know we can tell when
we came home from fourth grade and
there's 20 bunnies in the backyard all
laid like perfectly OCD with their heads
chopped off I'm like we probably started
a rehabilitating there but when he gets
to freaking
well if he has to bomb a place I hope
it's Lex that place is horrendous don't
say that take it back well maybe he
bombs when no one's there no okay fine
well he bombs he's not bombing anything
okay if he doesn't look crazy bones
there we go all right
um I I'm like we tried we tried when he
had the whole bunny syndrome we tried
when he had the coyote syndrome we tried
when he we found a kidnapped classmate
in his backpack you know
[__] okay so that's like obviously my
extreme but yeah those are my like the
way uh Bart PT Works that's my algorithm
is
um what is his immediate consequence so
if he like let's say
somehow everyone framed them some crazy
stuff happens and we know it's
punishable by death in this country but
I know in my heart of hearts I know in
my uh even based off evidence that he is
Innocent but I know in the game of U.S
law he will lose
we're leaving this country no turning
back that's tight so to me it's it's uh
intent
what is the immediate consequence and
where is it in my morals because you
know what is ethical and what is legal
or
two different things uh for sure yeah
yeah because legal is going to depend on
state by state country to Country
exactly some states yeah you sock me I
sock You Even Stevens yeah some states
you suck me I go first I sock you back I
get the bigger crime AKA California so
it's you know state state by state all
different so to me it's that's my like
chat gbt of how like I figure out um
how I would proceed you know what about
you
um same yeah yeah yeah same well you
said you had two scenarios what are your
two scenarios
um well the two would be that like
depending I mean you basically broke it
down so the first one would be like I
would turn them in to be like yo what
the fox that's the first one where I'd
be like yeah he's guilty take him away I
can't take his own life I can't do that
I'm not a psychopath I'm very normal I'm
very level-headed I have a lot of
emotions I have a big old heart
I feel things
but you rather turn them away to jail
where potentially other people can beat
them up and I don't know like if he's
that crazy
um
because he's in someone else's custody
now and when you're in someone else's
custody Anything Can Happen yeah but
what if he gets rehabilitated
he gets rehabilitated in solitary
confinement
I don't know so you don't think he
should pay for his crimes
I am I'm paying them for him you're
killing him yeah [__] yeah I guess I
guess I would have him be in someone
else's custody
I can't I can't do it like there's no
way if you want to truly pay for his
crimes this is what you would do the
seven thousand people he obliterated you
have a vote with all their parents do
you want my child in jail
or do you want my child to be gonzos
okay 50 50 split now what
some half of them want them in jail and
have them want um to be gonzos yeah
then uh we gotta probably do a game of
uh sudden death oh my God until there's
an actual yeah oh my God this is like a
[__] Korean horrible thing dude this
is a good one
um so that was the one one way that I'd
go uh and then the other one would be
like
um I would I would want to protect them
you know what I mean like I'm still his
mom but
knowing us like we do try to get her the
root of things and we don't just look at
one isolated incidents and we don't just
go we don't really Gap it off like we
really do work with him and I think we
would try our very best to do everything
in our our power our control with our
resources to see what we can do to
change that behavior
um yeah I can't take his life though
that thing is I can't do it every
parent's ever turned you in
I've never done anything that I needed
to get turned into oh well lucky for you
have they turned you in yeah my dad did
so did you feel betrayed are we like
he's a righteous man
um I don't know so in fourth grade
I was already like on a rocky
relationship with my pops because he uh
and my mom got divorced when I was in
first grade
so this is already like three years into
me seeing him only like once or twice a
week and only for a few hours during
those times
and my dad's like job was to pick me up
from school and either take me home or
take me to Kung Fu every day
um no for just Tuesdays and Wednesdays
and uh my dad one time you know like you
remember in fourth grade where like the
thing is like pencil boxes and pencils
and stuff like people yeah you want dope
[__] right like yeah whether like 20
bucks on pencils yeah whether it's
Sanrio or Morning Glory or even like the
American stuff like you just want cool
like little knickknacks so uh I told my
dad can you take me to save bonds which
is a drugstore
does it not exist anymore is that why
you said it like that well I don't know
some places you know like you know
there's hearties and crawls I see I see
so I just realized how like expansive
our audience is I just want to be
inclusive about it you know I just don't
want to like like rule anybody out
oh shut up right like I heard like like
Albertson's down here but NorCal Safeway
I just want to be really inclusive all
right go dude and so I just want to
Virtual signal like that okay any other
[__] words you want to highlight here
so um buzzwords so I haven't dropped me
off and I'm gonna pick up some uh you
know some stuff he drops me off I go and
I think I buy one
uh one like one of those you think you
buy one yeah because I remember like I
had to be smart enough not to just come
out with nothing so you knew you wanted
a Jackson [__] yeah I knew okay you
dropped me off I bought one but my
pockets were full of other [__] like
[__] lead lead pencils mechanical
erasers pens sick pens gel pens like
because you knew your parents would
never yeah so I just got [__] all
kinds of sick [__] and then um how sick
and this should be because Savon was
pretty whack well that stuff is
considered like what I had was
considered at least like the Ferrari of
pens and stuff there's no such thing as
a Ferrari in Savon well you don't know
what to look are you looking here are
you looking here okay go cause if you
look right here you can see a lot of
sick stuff like zebra I'm pretty tall so
I probably didn't see it um all those
sick Brands you know okay and then so uh
afterwards he took me to our go-to place
McDonald's McDonald's yep and then I'm
like I'll meet you at the cash register
I'm gonna go pee when I go in the
bathroom and I pee I go into the [__]
stall and I lock it and that's when I
start unpackaging stuff because you know
with packaging Things become really
really bulky so I'm packaged to take all
stuff out and then before I could even
get to it boom that door kicks open it's
my dad you know I [__] knew you stole
beat the [__] out of me right then and
there boom boom boom boom boom picks me
up drags me out of the place that is
filled with the smell of delicious
French fries throws me into his uh truck
were you crying
look out of me and then he took me back
to savon's and then he grabbed me by
like my collar pulls me in had me empty
my pockets on the counter and tells the
guy call the police right now my son
stole all this [__] oh my God okay how
did how did you feel there I was like
well first it was like a crazy surreal
surreal right I'm like how did he even
know and then come really slick he beat
the [__] out of me and then now he's
we'll start finding out how kids do it
yeah once Tyga starts doing it because
we think we're slick
but like my parents always be like you
think you [__] this is the first time I
invented that [__] yeah that's true
we'll probably see it that's true and
then um
yeah I just couldn't believe those words
that are coming my Dad's mouth I could
call the cops you know I was like what
the like what I like how you're judging
him yeah am I gonna go to jail like what
the [__] you should go to jail you
little [__] yeah I didn't call and then
the guy was like you know he's put on
the spot he said no that's okay maybe
just turn it back and just say sorry we
won't have to because who the [__]
gonna call a cop on like a I don't know
nine-year-old you know so he's like no
it's okay it's like I'm like Dad he's
saying like just just give it back goes
no you call police call police call
police he's like I'm no he's just saying
if I give it back and say sorry I'm just
like crying [__] like that and uh that
was the first time that I ever really
got turned in
and um
I was like
from that point on it never it didn't
stop me from stealing more
but it definitely made you sneakier no
it put a bookmark in my book though
about what
it I don't know it's just a very
memorable moment I see so I don't know
if I took like a negative away or a
positive away from that but it's
definitely like someone went through the
book you get to learn about your dad and
his character through that experience
that didn't do anything for you where
you're like oh this is my dad's type of
behind I guess so I guess what I learned
is my dad's righteous and you don't [__]
around that's tight so I was like oh
[__] like this is uh
but I think how I would want it to go is
if my dad told me I'm not going to call
the cops on you but I'm gonna [__] you
up I think I would have been like I
deserve oh we're family you know uh like
we take it we take care of it and family
because that's one thing I kind of liked
about like all my older like Youngs and
[__]
um growing up is
um they
never let anyone [__] with me
but that'll [__] me up more than anybody
else would ever [__] with me anyways but
I felt some sort of like weird love
through that you know yeah that is weird
like I'm like oh that fool was talking
[__] like my hands would just whoop
their ass
um and then they'll come and beat my ass
for other things
okay but I felt some sort of like
protective love you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's uh yeah that's [__] hard for a
parent so like now kind of taking it
to
the other one of where you're trying to
teach taika
um about like monogamy and relationships
and not telling a lot like would you he
say he's in that situation you know he
has a girlfriend so to the specific
situation that you're talking about yeah
because this one's not as nuts as like
mass murder you know what I'm saying
yeah well what would you do in that
situation or the cheating part
um I like the way my mom raised us where
she's going hey you're in that
relationship not me like you need to
deal with it whatever it is I'll back
you up I'll help you but I'm not gonna
meddle in it I'm not gonna um but isn't
that the mom backing him up oh he's in
the shower
um but not like that backing them up
where it's just you and I like she's not
gonna get involved with the thing you
know what I mean she would probably be
like I have no idea okay so Titus
girlfriend calls you uh-huh hey I can't
reach attack I don't know what's going
on
um I would hang up everything is not
there with you what do you say well he's
not here with me I don't know
I'm telling the truth right but if it
was one of those where I know now that
he's seeing another chick or whatever
um I would for sure be like
hey dude like that's not okay and this
is why it's not okay and I would have a
conversation like yo you really need to
settle this [__] because it's gonna get
really dirty or [__] up or like how
would you feel like I would have those
really heavy deep conversations with him
um but say she calls and she's like oh
but she said he said he was going to be
at your house like what you know has he
been there
um I'd be like huh I'm not I'm not sure
let me call you right back let me see
what's going on and then I'd call him
and be like yo what the [__] is going on
she just said this thing like are you
still [__] doing your stupid [__] I
would have it like that
you know where I'm talking to him but
I'm not I'm not
um siding with what if there's some sort
of sort of like intervention or like
um opening of the files if you will that
happens and they're like you stupid
[__] [__] I called you a new new too
what would you reply to that
um yeah but it's not my business
like that's between YouTube if you guys
want to do adult things you need to
handle adult things like [__] adults
right if you're gonna be in a [__]
adult relationship and the mom stepping
in you guys are not adults then yeah
that's true you need adult supervision
exactly you know what I'm saying so like
if they try to point it like that to me
I'm gonna be like then don't be in a
[__] relationship if you want Mommy
and Daddy to be around
yeah oh I can't wait why call me a
stupid [__] [__] oh really wait a
minute wait a minute yeah
so what about you
um and what what is the situation this
exact one sure yeah he's already been
cheating uh um
yeah uh yeah so you find out yeah
um how you find out
it could be on accident you found out on
accident what do you do now
so to me depends on the intent right
like I was saying okay so is
he is he even serious with this chick
does he view her serious how do you ever
know that I'll talk to my son I see do I
um did I think they're gonna get married
why didn't you know so many details
because I think it's all context I think
all rules are like you got to be smart
you have to be able to bend all the
rules
so for example if but isn't cheating
cheating no because it's lying lying is
lying if he's 30 versus he's 19 but it's
still lying versus 16. what's the
difference with ages so he's lying when
he's 16. that's correct
um but it's something that like for sure
everyone's feelings get certain but it's
not as serious versus he's engaged and
he cheats that's a big deal what is
happening
you know you already proposed to her you
committed to her yeah but you know what
I'm saying like I obviously I look down
at both but one I looked down harder at
well it's not obvious that's why I'm
asking questions you can't say obviously
because I when you said that I was just
like wait what how is it different yeah
I'm negative towards both okay good but
I like to ask questions to figure out
the scenario because the scenario
dictates the proper solution in my
opinion of course yes yes of course so
which is why I'm like is it a chick that
I don't even like to begin with she was
[__] rude to me at Thanksgiving and
then is it one of those I'm not excusing
his behavior but I'm trying to judge the
situation so I go is that the case or is
it like they were about to get engaged
they're both 33 what the [__] is going
on you know so if it's scenario one I'm
gonna be like oh yeah for sure he's uh
he's kicking right here I'll lie I got
his back you know and then I'll then
I'll talk to him like that's horrible
you're not letting him make good
decisions
well I gotta cover his tracks I don't
know if this [__] [__] is crazy what
if she's Korean who [__] wants to
stash all his tires yeah so he needs
daddy support for that like he needs to
again if you're going to be doing adult
[__] you need to act like a [__]
adult and that's why we have we're
together so you can handle these things
you know what I'm saying because it's
like it's like uh
skill what was that uh I don't know like
I think my area Mongolian chat it's like
an air bubble was going down my throat
um I think it was throat singing yeah so
it's like if you're gonna be doing adult
things you need to handle it like an
adult from day one so regardless if
she's being a complete super [__] to
me or you I'm not gonna like it nor am I
gonna like that chick but he needs to
solve that [__] all right take back my
answer what I'm gonna say is you know
what
my wife told me you guys are adults
adults need to do adults you gave it
away it doesn't do adult [__] so I'm
staying out of it I don't know anything
but you know what I'm saying like like
so now you're gonna cover his tracks
because he doesn't know how to one pick
a [__] healthy relationship yeah yeah
of course he's 16. of course he's gonna
have shitty Partners obviously that
comes with the territory but one he
picks really shitty Partners two he
allows his Partners to talk to his
parents who hopefully they have a
healthy relationship with he allows that
like if we keep meddling in with that
he's gonna expect that every time right
because he's never put in an
uncomfortable situation where he has to
face the ugly truth to now like
dismantle and like conquer that [__] so
that he learns from it to avoid it the
next time yeah
and then afterwards I'm gonna be like
taika every time you put me in that
situation again it's tense balls
context it's not inside jobs did you do
intense problems right now we have taika
doing tense brawls whenever he's like
um whenever he's not yeah whenever he's
rude or he has an attitude or he's
talking back or when he's making
careless mistakes with his homework
because since we all know now he has
ADHD he likes to just kind of like Zoom
through [__] because he wants to do the
next fun thing so
um we go all right double check your
work like if you get anything wrong
every wrong answer is going to be tense
brawls so that's where the 10 sprawls
comes in
um
but yeah if it's something that he can
control like cheating I I want I expect
him to deal with that on his own uh
facing the public on his own obviously I
want to consult him and talk to him and
and help navigate it I don't want to
solve his problems for him because
that's just not what I like I don't like
solving things though that uh situation
that you're describing
it is like if I look at the bright side
if I had to look at the Silver Lining
what is kind of cool is that dude's
relationship with his mom it is cool it
is the fact because there's a lot that
you can infer from it right one I'm
assuming it's not a last minute hey Mom
my [__] girlfriend's gonna call me
I'm cheating on her just just cover my
back because more than likely moms are
gonna go what the [__] is happening and
they're not gonna get your back when you
just throw it on them like that right
yeah chances are
so I'm assuming that it's been an
ongoing conversation right hey this
chick that I'm with
um I don't know you probably pitched it
all wrong too like she's a [__] I want
to get away from her I hate it yeah it
could be probably pitch it all wrong but
at the same time I have this other chick
that I like I don't know what to do so
what I'm inferring from it is what's
kind of cool
um if I infer correctly is that he has a
pretty open communication with his mom
yeah that he can walk the thoughts
through and have back and forth to the
point of hey Mom can you help me and
that is kind of cool because I don't
think it is cool that's not something I
could have ever even dreamed of
uh asking my parents it's CUNY it's cool
but the way I like to think and I've
we've discussed this many times in the
moment it's CUNY and it's warm and it's
like ah like I can hide and my mom's
like [__] kind of like put a blanket
over me and like
cuddle me right yeah and that is CUNY
and I love it it makes my heart very
warm
but I like to think in 5 10 20 30 year
increments and I'm like okay but how
else
is this kind of like me pacifying this
Behavior like where else is this gonna
like come up to where he doesn't even
know how to solve that situation oh for
me uh every time I get his back
he answers no he owes me one
what do you mean how it all depends how
does he owe you like what would what
would so I'm old school yeah with the k
okay old school with the K okay okay
you're [__] stupid
all right all right so don't don't get
it twisted okay don't get it twisted
if I cover you oh my God okay yeah but
what the [__] are you doing that needs
covering bro if I cover it no I'm
covering for taika yeah if I'm cover you
yeah
afterwards we're going behind the
dumpster and I'm socking you in the
stomach like three times
oh [__] you owe me but you're [__]
old now like how bad is that Gonna Hurt
you're not gonna be a vivacious it's
vibrant take steroids for six months
just for that because you know he's
gonna [__] up increase my protein and
then work only on right Hooks and get a
boxing coach
and then I'm gonna sock him in his
stomach three times
and you think that's going to teach him
a lesson of manhood
uh no it was just teaching him that his
dad's gonna [__] his ass up no what it
teaches him is there's Rules to This
jungle
and we live in a jungle yeah but the
right people aren't putting the [__]
the consequences on him it doesn't
matter it does matter that's why it
depends on the jungle right I'm telling
you some jungles a new lion from another
pride comes kills this Mother's babies
this mother gets horny [__] that lion
so it's the rules of the streets it's
which rules you abide by I abide by my
rules but that jump if I got your back
son
you [__] owe me
yeah then he's not gonna go to you no he
well he will I mean
he's just gonna be by himself no he'll
go to Mama then but he'll know no one
gets me
like my dad
but it comes with the price
you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah it comes with the
[__] price so you better think
twice
before you ask nice
let's say the word I don't know
yeah it's [__] hard man like when I
try to think of [__] like that
like obviously I can only give you like
answers that I've worked through in my
own brain with my own made-up scenarios
but when the time comes like I don't
really know what I'm gonna do yeah
because there's at least three other
curveballs you never thought 100 you
know or like now he gets her pregnant
now he has two chicks pregnant I'm like
oh my [__] God I thought I taught you
better than this
it's [__] hard yeah um but ultimately
I do want to have his back growing up I
didn't feel like
my mom had much of my back honestly
um and it was more specific to like with
my dad and now I get it now that I'm
married and I like I have we have taika
and [__] and like he tries to divide us
where he's like Mom can I do this and
I'm like no and then like he waits and
he walks to you hey Dad can I do this
and then you heard me say no and he's
like and you're like why do you ask me
me and your mom were a team like we're
not gonna go We're not gonna like he
tries to not or even if I don't hear
what you said I'll go what did Mom say
and he goes oh Mom said yeah I'm like
she really said yeah
you better think long and hard before
you [__] own me to take it to the
[__] the jungle [__] you three times
you know yeah no Mom said no I'm like
okay good
yeah but like now looking back at why
she would choose my dad over me I'm like
I get it you know like they're their
partnership like they are loyal to each
other but growing up it didn't feel like
she had much of my back but she didn't
also um mediate
that's probably something she could have
worked on
I guess so I guess I don't really know
what happens behind the scenes maybe she
tried and he overpowered her you know
what I mean like we don't really know
well no because you would know if she
mediated
because you would be the only one that
knew so for example
when taika thinks you're a [__]
and he comes and talks to me and I can
tell in his mind he goes man mom's being
a [__] [__] right now I'm immediate
I mean why did Mama do this or why did
Mama Like take that away from you or my
why did Mama say you can't have Donuts
well because I was acting bad whatever
and like you know I help unravel this
[__] knot in his brain and he
understands more and more and more so
when he has a mom's a [__] [__]
at least all right tone it down at least
she he leaves with I understand my mama
had my back I understand yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah right maybe or maybe she
didn't I just wasn't listening as an
adolescent kid
maybe I mean she also didn't have the
same tools that we have yeah we
literally can go [__] go on Instagram
and then there's like 10 ways to be a
better mom you know yeah yeah yeah
it's true but yeah I think for our kid
because I felt that kind of divide
before like to me it's very important
and I like
um I always liked the everyone suffers
together mentality yeah I like that too
so like I would see you know like two
two kids fighting in a family
and then
um they're fighting oh Josh Hit Me No
Jim hit me whatever I'm like I don't
give a [__] both of you guys are doing
push-ups right now I like it right so
it's like you guys I don't give a [__]
who started doesn't even matter you guys
are brothers you and Mia Mia taika is in
the room right now yeah yeah you both
[__] give me 10 lines yeah you guys I
don't give a [__] you guys shouldn't you
guys are brothers shouldn't be true like
that I don't like when there are
favorites
well that's the sister whatever little
brother and then I think that's when it
creates a divide yeah and when you
create a divide even though you could
have a big family you don't feel like
you're in a family you know yeah that's
that's what I that's uh what I don't
like yeah yeah I don't like that either
because you know like you know when you
do
um I don't think I don't even think
people do it on purpose you know for
sure they don't do it on purpose it's
their own
lack of thinking because you know when
you go to a team like like any sports
team that's one of the dopest things
about it it's like oh okay so guess what
Geo wants to be late everyone thank Geo
for the next 10 laps yeah right and it's
like you everyone's like [__] Jill but
it's also like everyone's keeping
everyone on check yeah because when
Jenna's late everyone's running 10 laps
too when Jenna misses the ball or
whatever you know and so it's uh it's a
theme where everyone stays China sucks
well she got nice titties and so
everyone stays together why am I weird
because you thought of Jenna's titties
you're so [__] weird what sport did
they I don't know
basketball no it's a new sport I don't
even heard of it you're [__] weird go
ahead what
um well yeah we're gonna talk to you
about my genre get her back like that
all right yeah she got nice things don't
be talking [__] about my channel so what
happened when um when I was when you
were saying how if the girl talks [__]
to you and you're like yeah yeah [__]
her anyway like who cares well you're
basically solving his problems
and then you're my like it was like a
switch of mine switch when I was like
what the [__] so for me it was let's say
she's he's with the crazy [__] and I
know she's a [__] crazy [__] from
day one
um and my son's too [__] to break it
off like a man and so I'm just trying to
extinguish if you will extinguish the
fire as much as I can
on the front end on the back end I'm
going to talk to him about you need a
man the [__] up the next time one of
your girlfriends [__] calls me on my
phone I don't even know why this
[__] has my phone number because
you guys aren't getting married I don't
know where she got that from but the
next time that happens it's gonna be six
socks in the stomach behind the dumpster
you know
you wouldn't even want them to have your
phone number
not if she's a [__] crazy ass [__]
if they're like if it's good to me
that's what it's all about intent and
context and all that right if I'm like
oh man I see marriage between them and I
see the way he talks about them and what
I'm like yeah give them a phone number
I'll be here a second dad now
you know
but if not
like you remember one of the first
presents I bought for you I talked to
your mom hella to get you that camera
I think your mom already liked me or he
probably like accepted me into your
family
right but if you're if your mom thought
I was like some [__] sleaze ball
she probably wouldn't want to pick up my
phone or anything like that yeah yeah
like that so I would be like
um
it depends depends who it is
but [__] you better keep my name out
of your [__] oh no
and and now that I said what I said
um about that crazy [__] scenario what
are your thoughts now
um
I like yours because I think mine is
still kind of like
Hood Justice
whereas I think yours is it actually
props them up to be to handle things
because I think I'm still kind of
involved you know I'm still kind of like
the village leader trying to like do
this but I think as much as there is
involvement I'm taking away a chance for
him to build his own tools yeah so as
yeah I think as a dad I asserted myself
too much so actually like your your
approach where no you're an adult now
I'm gonna have zero involvement whereas
mine I was still
put out the fire in the front
uh make him understand at the end but if
his actions caused the crazy Korean
[__] to slash his tires and break his
windshield that's something he just has
to go through I can't get ahead of him
and try to like alleviate that you know
yeah yeah throw the pillows down as you
would say yeah yeah I think that's very
very important people got to learn the
lessons and that's the best way to learn
yeah you have to fail you have to ah
yeah and again it's all easy when I'm
sitting in the comfort of my own home
filming a podcast very level-headed
right now you know like I'm just having
my coffee like I I feel good I mean
we've all seen the no dog on the bed
rule what the [__] and we've all seen
how many times Mia has been sleeping on
the bed we've seen that ever since I
washed our bed she hasn't come up I mean
it's nice that she hasn't slept on her
bed for two days not two days stop it I
washed the bed last Saturday but when
you love someone and it's barely Friday
it's hard you know when you love someone
I understand you become a big softy in
his heart yeah
yeah I don't know what I'm gonna do
when it actually happens hopefully I can
like repeat this [__] to myself and just
really hold on to like he needs to make
his own mistakes he needs to learn I'm
just there as a guide
um when I was watching Kanye West's
documentary
what is it called
I don't know but it's on Netflix not a
genius right
is it genius it's something like that
yeah or some [__] anyway so there's a
lot of footage because it it records
like when he was hustling to become the
Kanye that we know now yeah when he was
just like putting in the work and he's
just a producer yeah
he just popped off as a producer and he
wanted to break out of that
um but there's a lot of footage of his
mom like and him who were like super
tight like they're super best friends
yeah
um and I really liked it but something
that
kind of like I had a slight paradigm
shift to was I forgot what the question
or what the prompt was but she replied
she she says oh I'm done parenting him
like I'm his friend now
like it's not like I'm not his parent
anymore like obviously she's saying I am
his parent but she's like I'm not I'm
not here to parent anymore
like I'm his friend like I genuinely
want to see him succeed and I was like
that's so [__] tight because yeah
there's some times where
um like now we have to like severely
parent because we need to guide him a
lot of the time right because he's gonna
he doesn't understand the consequences
to his actions or like
you know like Tantrums or controlling
emotions or whatever
but then understanding at what point you
need to back off on the parenting and
and be okay with just being a friend
that really wants to support him what do
you think about the saying um I'm not
your friend I'm your parent I say that
[__] all the time
really you don't hear me because at the
same time you're like you're my best
friend
who says that you I mean because he says
that to me because it's CUNY talk so
what is it are you his friend or his
parent
um right now I'm his parent and he can't
talk to me like his friend because he he
doesn't know how to it's the true
definition of that is I don't want to
know anything about you
from a eye to eye level I only want to
know things about you from a top-down
down up level yeah so in our actuality
the way we parent it is actually pretty
friend parent you know like we parent we
try to mold them and stuff but there's a
lot of times we just talk and we really
like you know I think we're trying to
have the relationship that we didn't
have with our parents right our parents
was Zero friends it was all parent all
kids you know well I say that in more of
a respect your elders type of way I know
but I'm saying it and what do you think
about that traditional way of bringing
kids up where up to 18 I'm your parent
18 and on I'm your friend I don't think
it's a number
type thing because like let's say he
starts showing me in like seventh grade
he's super honorable he comes to us and
tells us what his next college thing is
going to be like he's very involved in
his own life then at that point I'm like
oh [__] my guidance here is going to be
very minimal like now he's just gonna
pick he's gonna pick my brain for my
wisdom right like Mom how do I open up a
bank account or like hey Mom like how do
I fill up my application papers like
it's not going to be something where I'm
going to be like okay don't drink and
drive let me smell your breath okay you
know what I mean like that's not
parenting anymore
um so if he shows me he's capable of
controlling his own life then at that
point I can like completely take
uh take my hands off the wheel okay I
think you can drive yourself so do you
think but I'm still watching gotcha so
do you think um so for you parenting and
friendship is kind of like
it's uh
maybe in the beginning it's like 99 or
90 10 and depending on how he's
developing
it it goes from back and forth
I don't know if I view it like that
apparently because the way that I view
it is this is the difference between
parenting and friendship right both the
mission is the benefit of the other
person right
parenting is this
friendship is this hey dude I think you
should probably go work out you want to
go work out with me dude I've been
training dude I lost 15 pounds I got a
lot of muscle I got way better Jiu Jitsu
I didn't want to get better Jitsu no
okay cool that's uh friendship
parenting is like you're going to
jujitsu
you're gonna train if you don't train
you're not watching TV you know like
friendship is like hey dude there's this
new like zero eight percent uh APR
credit card I think you should sign up
for it and I know you have some debt you
know yeah yeah then it's parenting is
sign up for the credit card now yeah by
tomorrow if I check and all the other
credit cards aren't Consolidated on this
credit card you lose this right so to me
it's like it's different
um so I think that phrase of
um your I'm your parent not your friend
it's more like I have rules yeah and you
follow them yeah I don't give a [__] how
you feel yeah and then usually it's like
okay I did my job in all these rules
your age of maturity now let me get to
know you that's I think that's that
mindset that school of thought yeah and
what was your question
um are you more towards that or for you
is it kind of like you run to at this
it's kind of a hybrid for sure
um whereas right now I'm leaning more on
the parenting side but I do want him to
know that there is this like open line
of communication where I I can be
vulnerable to and I'm not just like the
[__]
the rule Enforcer
or the rule maker
um I do try as often as I possibly can I
do try to explain the philosophy behind
the rule I know a lot of the times it's
probably falling on deaf ears because
he's five yeah
um but just through my experience with
raising him
things stick you know not the whole
thing but like the gist of what I'm
trying to say will stick you know
um so I just stick to that where I'm
like I'm gonna try to explain it every
single time and then little by little
you start building your own blogs and it
just kind of falls into place for you
um
and also he's five so I think the
Friendship part of it right now is is
very minimal just because I'm everything
to him
he doesn't know anything else
do you know what I mean I don't think so
I actually disagree what yeah
so like this is my feeling because and
this is me correcting myself okay
um in the beginning
like I think it's easy to minimize
people that are young oh he's only five
whatever right so my ignorance was
almost like he's not enough of a person
to be friends with you
you know what I mean like if I were to
interface with him his connection points
are three snacks
looking for Treasures or whatever right
so those are huge so those other things
that I I'm trying to connect I can't
really connect with him which is why you
don't see 40 year olds hanging out with
eight-year-olds very much because
there's just not too much to connect
you're not enough of a person to connect
you right which is why I like people of
the same class experience they can
connect because that's the world's all
the same so they interface like a
thousand points right that's how I
viewed it so for me it was very easy for
me to parent because I'm like you don't
know [__] I tell you everything you do
everything I do
but I also realize the problem with that
is that's it becomes a relationship like
me and my parents and it's not until
you're older then you get to have all
this uncovering and then you kind of
like repair both the present and the
past at the same time
so what I realized is when I am able to
take my parenting brain away
and sometimes I'm like okay close the
controlled environment we did what he
needed to do he he worked out he did his
homework he ate his food
um now I don't think anything can go
wrong in this environment I throw the
parenting away and I'm gonna connect
with him as a person
um then when I zoom in it's almost like
like Bug's Life you know how you zoom in
now like like yeah yeah the grass is
like 10 feet tall yeah Dew of water
becomes this big so when I'm at his
level I'm like
he'll share up with me about his lizards
about acorns like how like if he acorns
what does it becomes a tree yeah does it
become a tree yeah like all that stuff
right and I realized like oh man like if
I always just parent I miss out on all
of this yeah all of this Bug's Life view
of things so I'm just looking top down
yeah and I also not only do I miss out
on this
the times that
um
you would need to parent because you
think they don't know so I'm just force
him yeah it's easy a lot of it happens
here the little mechanics because he's
explaining the world that he sees that I
think most adults
dismiss actually yeah like that's not
important like but now I'm in this world
with him and I can help him like see
this Bug's Life World so as he becomes
taller than the grass he comes with the
tools yeah yeah
um and what did I see that prompted you
to say that
um I don't know I was just sure okay was
it something that I said where you're
like I don't because you're like I don't
see it like that oh yeah what was the
thing I said I forgot cool
um but yeah I don't see it like that
um
because
maybe I just prove your point I don't
even know
um I was just sharing kind of like
Epiphany that I had so okay I I I
remember what happened
um so I was talking about how I'm
parenting more now than being a friend
right yeah
um and what you're talking about to me
is what I view as nurturing his person
um so what you're calling friendship
yeah is me just nurturing his interests
nurturing and building up his confidence
um so I don't really see it as a friend
just yet what's the difference between
nurturing and being a friend to you I
guess I don't know but I guess that's
why it didn't it didn't click to me that
I am being his friend because to me I
think that is being his friend yeah
maybe but I'm saying like I didn't I did
it didn't click to me at that moment and
that's why when you said what you just
finished saying I'm like I do the same
thing because we do have those same
conversations and he's talking to me
about everything he learns in school and
just like the lizards and the acorn and
we do have you know like now every time
at dinner now he asks because I started
the trend he asks so what do you what
what's your favorite thing yeah you know
and every day at dinner we really get to
like have deep conversations or as deep
as they can be for taika but they're
like pretty deep yeah about like his his
likes his dislikes his you know what
makes him excited what makes him nervous
um but yeah I didn't I didn't see it as
a friendship but maybe that's exactly
what I'm doing you know
um where maybe this is the Libra side of
me but I do really try to keep a balance
because as much as I'm Drilling and
trying to instill
um morals and ethics and and respect and
self-confidence you know I'm also trying
to remember how it felt for me
not having that out later not having
people listen to me or not people like
people really dismissing you know things
that were big to me right like if I was
crying over not being able to call my
best friend that day for most adults
it's like who cares you're gonna see
them at school in a couple hours anyway
like get over it you know but for a kid
that's huge it is this big water you
know it is Ant World yeah or or the
movie ends bugs life Bug's Life it is it
is Bug's Life you know it's like but
that is my world that is my biggest
thing today and the thing I've been
looking forward to Forever like this is
my Christmas and you're telling me that
it doesn't mean anything yeah so because
that was something that I carried with
me for so many years and something that
just made me so sad that like I'm very I
I I try to at least when I'm not [__]
when I don't have my head up my own ass
with my own [__] that I'm dealing with
you know like at work or whatever
um when I can see it I'm like oh [__]
this is a big deal for him you know
um so I was seeing it as like I'm just
being the person I didn't have to him
yeah I didn't really have this uh like
Epiphany until maybe this year
uh the the which one like oh the
parenting like going in on him yeah
because I think if I had to
um boil down my emotions and feelings
towards him or just towards children in
general from a parent to a child I think
my two main emotions
is responsibility
and um
reward
and so responsibility is like making
sure he's fed making sure he learns his
manners making sure he can operate in
society right there's all these things
and I feel like in our parents
generation
that's 99 of parenting do this eat your
vegetables blah blah blah it's just
constantly One Way communication right
yeah and then so there's that part that
I feel like that's what's instilled in
me I better raise a successful
productive person of society that has
honor and all that [__] and all that
[__] right
what [__] all that [__] and then the
reward part of it though is during the
times where like I'm able to slow down
because I think you're usually on
obligation mode right they work okay you
gotta make food okay make the food and
then you gotta eat are you [__]
eating I'm [__] go sleep soon we're
just gonna have a [__] seizure God
damn it you know it's like you're in
that [__] you're in that mode right
yeah um then
you kind of miss
the beauty of knowing who he is
and so I it was it wasn't really until
like maybe this last year where a lot of
times and I think what helped me get
there was a lot of our hikes you know
like I just knew that when we're hiking
he can be himself and I don't have to
this don't do this or whatever like he
could chuck a rock he could do whatever
he could talk to me about how oh did you
know that that oh did you see the cactus
that's strange the cactus growing on the
dirt over there like I get to know him
and that is like a different type of
relationship and like that's why I call
it reward because it's not this way it's
more like me getting this way yeah and
then the reward part me the more I know
him the more rewarding it is and like
the more I know that like he doesn't
like gel he likes hairspray like even
all those small things you really get to
know him and that's like has been so
enjoyable for me
yeah and I didn't really realize like
that's kind of like my um like clutch
and accelerator
when I'm like like obviously if I see
something glaring like don't do that
whatever or hug hug hug your Theos and
Theos and stuff like that but then
um also like being able to
like oh how come you don't like hugging
that deal
got smells or whatever and I'm like I
get to like know more about
who this person is you know yeah it's
very very CUNY that is CUNY
yeah I guess um
yeah that's something uh
that just came it wasn't an epiphany
that I had I've always been like that
with kids
just because I've seen it you know I see
parents with their heads up their asses
and when I say heads up their asses I
don't mean it in a bad way I mean so
more so like the obligation part yeah
they just can't they're just overwhelmed
with the applications of Life yeah they
just they can't you know they can't slow
down they can't let go of the thing that
they're holding on to us everything gets
[__] yeah
um so anytime I do come across kids like
that I just become a kid like them and
not a kid like them to where I'm like
[__] being goofy and like like acting
their age but I'm definitely listening
yeah and I'm asking questions and I
always see kids really gravitate towards
that because I think they don't get it
and I'm like
it's hard you know what the thing is
it's like the obligations of life
you feel like you can't but you can you
can't what like they feel like they
can't slow down to get to the other side
but you always can like I've seen I
don't know how many times I've seen
parents so like at Disneyland for
example or Disney World or even
traveling abroad right I I can't
like P parents are so funny uh parrots
oh like parents are so focused on having
a good trip they don't have a good trip
yeah you know what I mean yeah like
Logistics let's be on time yeah let's
get all the tickets you have your stuff
yeah and it's going on okay we got to go
to lunch now is everyone ready you guys
go it's still an obligation versus like
that's what I mean head in their ass
yeah yeah and then they had zero bonding
for a week even though they had the
whole trip together yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah how do you slow that down
like how do you take time you have to
constantly remind yourself because you
think I think everyone thinks that there
is like the the a story that's at Play
but the beat the truth in the cherish
and uphold is the B story yet I don't
know what that means so would it be
something like uh you know the saying
like it's not about the destination it's
about the journey yeah
so is that what you're talking about
like slowing it down more in that regard
so if if it comes to the vacation then
it's going all right well [__] it all
plans out the window where do you want
to eat today Johnny well I mean I think
plans are great
um because you plan with your head but
know that you're really traveling for
your heart
so if if you're how do you travel for
your heart versus your head so your
heart is I want to bond I want to be
with my family for a whole week it's
spring break you know I want to get to
know
where do you start how do you start
spend time and use your heart try to
connect with their heart versus okay so
that's what the goal is now your plan
right which is good so now okay you know
what's good uh Johnny really likes uh
hockey so we're gonna go we're gonna go
to this hockey place we're gonna do it
and do all these things right but after
that go back to your heart
when you're at the hockey game whether
you're late or not whatever that's not
important what's important is watching
the game with your kid and like making
sure you it's hard because it's so
that's not how our brains function you
know our brains are so like frontal
cortex that like we want to solve
problems yeah that's what they're there
for but that's that's how we end up
losing the connection because we're so
focused on solving the problem yeah the
a story part of it you know like like
what is on paper versus the subtext of
what we're trying to get to yeah
parenting is so hard
it's very hard
but you're a pretty good parent I'm all
right you're all right
I'm pretty stoked with our life changes
that are happening now
you know where I get to be more of a
parent I'm pretty stoked about that
sorry my sword is kind of choking me a
bit
um
yeah I'm pretty stoked on that for sure
yeah I'm learning a lot about the dude
he's a CUNY guy
but my my goal with him is to always
make him
um a stand-up dude where he just he's
given
he's given the guidance
um
so that he can craft his own tools and
these tools are the right tools you know
not the tools that are gonna like hurt
[__] thousands of people yeah
yeah the other day I was thinking and I
don't know if this is going to be
accurate because it's not a complete
thought
oh I don't even know if it relates to
this
never mind it doesn't relate to this
perfect
sorry sorry okay well I'll just say it
because now it's [__] weird
um but I was just saying how you know
there's different types of
um personalities on this planet right
there's like a ton or maybe there's even
a handful right like there's just types
of people
um and then you have your go-getters
that's a type of person like the people
that are like really about obtaining
what it is that they want like they're
these hungry people
um
and it's just so interesting to me that
depending on the the nurturing of that
of that personality
if it's nurtured for good then they can
do amazing things right but if it's
unurtered or just if they so happen to
go on the path uh of where it's nurtured
for bed
then they go on a completely different
path someone like
um kind of like you
right where
um growing up you're a really smart kid
but your home was so cold and broken
that you needed to fill that void of a
of the warmth and and togetherness that
you found a gang right but imagine if
you didn't have that
like what your life would look like now
you know so I just thought I just found
that so interesting that like
um what seems like something that is so
simple or um
I mean this really does it does I guess
I don't know it seems simple on paper
that like if you do good and you help
instill good and you
are able to focus on your kids and and
nurture the good in them
that like they can
Propel and be something great in life
that's all
I see but yeah that's what the thought
was where I was just like damn it's it's
like you know life can be really simple
and we just complicate things like crazy
life is very simple that's the point of
it all I'm like it just kind of blew my
mind of like the Simplicity of things
where I'm like why do we make things so
[__] complicated like why do we have
to add so many obstacles and and all
these uh explanations to things that
don't need explanations like it really
is simple you know operate with love
operate with respect well the rules the
the solutions to life are simple but
life is sophisticated
you know it's like everyone knows if you
eat less than you need you lose weight
oh but it's uh Matthew's birthday on
Thursday and he loves buffets boom what
do you do here's a test
you know oh [__] it's uh oh guess what
guys at work we hit
um the kpis we wanted this quarter big
celebration chocolate cakes all around
someone brought Donuts in do you say no
you know oh cool uh Jenny
um is brought her brought her famous
vegetarian dumplings brought it for
everybody because she really cares do
you say no
you know it's like it's like the the
keys are are easy
but then life is like
[__] speed Bumps and Jumps and gaps
everywhere yeah [__] life I'm just
kidding yeah yeah it's a complicated
thing but it's good to know that at
least we have each other's backs and we
have taika's best interest in mind and
if he is a [__] lying little snaky
cheater
um the one sock them up no we're gonna
make him confront his issues like a
[__] and his problems like a [__]
man even if he was a woman like if taika
was a
I would have the exact same solution
like no [__] you need to [__] solve
your problems like a goddamn woman no
but put your big draws on you need a
phase die [__] yeah like I'm not I
wouldn't treat I'll suck her up too
no you wouldn't you would not talk her
up or what no you wouldn't you wouldn't
even suck up Tycoon soccer up three
times in the stomach all right fine you
little veterano on that note is there
anything else you want to add no anyone
you want to shout out
uh yes shout outs to bartleburgain we're
also sponsoring this podcast obvious
it's our own brand but it helps us
support this podcast so if you want
anything uh apparel supplements digital
training we have a strength program that
I'm running right now to get the
strongest I've ever been and I've been
crushing all my weights if you follow me
on my stories go to bottlebrigade.com
it's your One Stop Shop for all your
Fitness dope needs to check it out
see ya bye